been leaked a document from the heart of
government which reveals the exact words
that Attorney General Geoffrey Cox used
on a conference call last month when he
was outlining the the legal argument in
favor of a prorogation of parliament to
the rest of the cabinet when Boris
Johnson was briefing the cabinet for
this exceptional event which has been
overturned by the Supreme Court today
now for the Attorney General Jeffrey Cox
recommended that the cabinet and the
government go ahead with this because it
was completely legal and the details of
the cabinet call were published by the
High Court last month as part of the
disclosure documents that led to this
Supreme Court case that culminated today
but the section I'm about to read you
was redacted the five or so lines at the
bottom of one of the pages
what blacked out deemed too sensitive to
reveal to the public but Sky News has
obtained them right now let me read them
to you they say the Attorney General
told his cabinet colleagues the Attorney
General said that his advice on the
question of whether or not this was
lawful was that this was lawful and
within the Constitution any accusations
of unlawfulness or constitutional
outrage were motivated by political
considerations and then he said that the
proposal was compatible with a piece of
recent Northern Ireland emergency
legislation so let's just put that in
context this morning the 11 Supreme
Court justices ruled unanimously that a
court could decide whether prorogation
was legal and did decide that this
predation was not legal but the
government acting on the advice of the
Attorney General the most senior law
figure in the government the government
the cabinet was told on a conference
call last month that this wouldn't
happen that this moment wouldn't arise
because it was lawful and constitutional
I think this is deeply embarrassing for
Jeffrey Cox I've spoken to Downing
Street in the last half an hour since
getting the document they made clear
that they're not going to comment on
this I'm sure that lots of other people
will wade in is extraordinary blame game
to be had about how the government ended
up in this mess
but what is clear is that the Attorney
General said it would be fine and it
wasn't fine so questions for him
it's a kir stahma in the last 10 minutes
for suggesting that Sir Geoffrey courts
may have to resign over this issue what
do you think Sam it's certainly
incredibly embarrassing for him isn't it
I think that this is just part of a
tsunami of bad news for Boris Johnson
today the issue of legal advice has been
troubling cabinet ministers ever since
this issue first came up we've heard
reports that Julian Smith in cabinet was
asking for fuller advice Boris Johnson
says yes I'll get it to you and then it
never emerged I know other cabinet
ministers are deeply worried about Boris
Johnson's approach to the law his hints
and his suggestions that he might be
prepared to break it don't forget he was
the one that gave that interview to the
mail on Sunday the prime minister Cooke
comparing himself to the Incredible Hulk
and suggesting he can break free of the
manacles of laws that he doesn't like
that is an awkward situation for other
cabinet ministers many of whom are
lawyers themselves to find themselves in
but um I suppose it's part of the
defence of Boris Johnson that here he
has his attorney general one of the most
respected Kesey's in the land saying it
was legal but it's embarrassing for
Geoffrey Cox that when it was tested it
was found not to be